[Music]
not so long ago
the question should we teach patriotism
in schools would have seemed a strange
one
the answer would have been of course
today
the role of patriotism in schooling is
controversial generally supported on the
right
and greeted skeptically by many on the
left those of us who embrace patriotism
believe that students need to appreciate
the sacrifices
so many have made to secure our freedoms
and all that unites us
as americans indeed a healthy patriotism
is inextricably bound to american civic
health
to skeptics patriotism is a term
freighted with partisanship
tinged with xenophobia and often viewed
as a divisive rhetorical ploy
regardless of these larger debates
though i think that most americans would
agree
that students should learn about what's
worth cherishing in our rich history
and also the many many ways we can do
better in extending
and upholding the american legacy in the
end
whether we call that patriotism or
something else may just be semantics
what does patriotic education mean to
you let us know in our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos
from aei